we gotta do this let's engage
[Music]
hey guys
okay
nothing's gonna go back to the way that
it was
[Music]
not really I saw something
what is it
[Music]
No I felt it
haha darkness falls across the land the
midnight hour is close at hand creatures
crawl in search of blood to terrorize
y'all's neighborhood whoever shall be
sometimes I feel like mr. su must stand
and face the hounds of hell
what inside of corpses shell
whoever is happening
is spreading from this place
[Applause]
[Music]
right
if your actors
give you something
[Laughter]
hey youtubers is Charlie you thought
that comic-con was over no there is so
much more comic-con stuff so let's talk
about stranger things this is great I
always love it when they released the
extended trailers there will be a bunch
more comic-con stuff posting next week
so be sure to subscribe to get that
stranger things season 2 isn't actually
dropping til Halloween this year but
they'll be releasing more promos through
the course of the year but you kind of
see how the trailer is a tour de force
of 80s references so you have Michael
Jackson's Thriller you have zombie
Michael Jackson sitting in the upside
down somewhere just watching this
enjoying everything they start off with
this great last starfighter reference
married to a Dragon's Lair reference
both impossible games let me know in the
comments if you're somebody who played
dragon's lair and was able to beat it
because it was pretty nuts but obviously
they're using the game footage to show
how they're going to be fighting the big
villain the dragon in this game and
they're gonna get roasted a little bit
like they all get destroyed and it's
sort of a metaphor for the these'll
Hydra at the end of season 1 setting up
the thing that was responsible for
creating the demo Gorgon so this is the
thing that's sort of speaking to will in
the trailer like he's having visions of
it almost like it aloud will to escape
and is using him as sort of a bridge
showing how the upside down is slowly
bleeding into the real world like you
see all these pumpkins rotting in the
real world will keeps flashing back and
forth and then you hear that voice over
this hasn't ended like the idea that
even though will is back things are only
gonna get worse for him so he's back
being experimented on with the Hawkins
National Laboratory so even though that
seemed like it was kind of destroyed at
the end of season 1 Matthew Modine
character is still a big thing so he's
the one that's responsible for all this
testing so it seems like they're a
little more willing to work with each
other just because they know things are
so crazy now that they kind of have an
understanding of what's going on you see
sheriff hopper notice some of the goo on
the tree so it's just more of the upside
down bleeding into the real world like
you see will slowly go crazy as he's
making all these drawings of the big
these'll Hydra that's what we can call
it for now they might have a different
name for it when we actually get to
season 2 because they didn't reveal that
many details in their comic-con panel
but the footage total
redeemed them now Sadie you are joining
the kids you are playing so how do you
interact with them what if you like best
about the first season but then you also
kind of hear will trying to speak to 11
who looks like she's just been stuck in
the upside down since she took down the
demagogue on so she just slowly finds a
weak point between worlds pushes through
so there's really two things that you
take away from this yay Elevens back
that's really cool this is how she comes
back but also oh [ __ ] because the
barrier between the upside down in the
real world is starting to weaken like
she just found this right next to her
it's not like she had to walk all the
way to that special entrance at the
Hawkins National Laboratory basement
like I said the series is premiering in
October around Halloween it's also
around Halloween in the world of the
show which is why you see all the
trick-or-treat fan bear why you see them
in the Ghostbusters costumes because
that's who they're dressing up as on
Halloween they even have the proton
packs and the Ghostbuster traps it looks
like they try to trap something from the
upside down Ghostbuster style you all
remember how that first movie ended they
tried to contain a whole bunch of
monsters but they all spilled out into
the real world so that implies that's
what's going to be happening during
season two is that Ghostbusters style
you have this nuclear breach where the
upside down just spills into the real
world so give me all your theories about
the these'll Hydra and what's going to
be happening but they'll continue making
stranger things for season 3 season 4
season 5 there are a couple new
characters that they introduced I don't
see Sean Astin in the trailer anywhere
so maybe they'll start teasing them when
we get a little bit closer but they
wanted to focus mostly on the characters
from season 1 and what's different about
season 2 but beyond all this footage
there is a lot more new stuff that's
happening so just let me know what you
guys are most excited about I know
there's a Westworld season 2 trailer
I'll do a video for that next
there's Walking Dead I've already gotten
a bunch of requests for videos but if
there is comic-con stuff that I haven't
done yet that you guys want me to do
just let me know in the comments new
Game of Thrones episode posting later
tonight while you wait for everything
you can click here for all the Comic Con
trailers starting with Thor Ragnarok and
you can click here for the Game of
Thrones episode 2 trailer thank you so
much for watching everybody stay awesome
I'll see you guys tonight